And 3, 2, 1, action
A little bit to
So can i see you...
You're on his shoulders
Action
You're alive?!
So those guys...
So those guys are in the middle of shooting a video right now
and we just got word that the Corridor Digital and the Sam and Niko channels
have been hacked.
There's somebody on Twitter who actually
tagged me and I saw it
I saw the quick, I checked it out and I came to you guys right away.
So while everybody's busy shooting the next Corridor Digital video
me and Carmichael are gonna have to sit down and figure out how to fix this problem.
Let's focus.
I'm going to disable
All third-party apps.
Also need to change the host e-mail of the account.
I have to wipe all the permissions to the accounts
Here's so you can see what the hack looks like.
The names are changing to the videos.
It's still growing.
So, Sam and Niko and Corridor has been hacked.
What?
Yes, somebody is changing all the names as they are going down the timeline.
Dude, what happened?
I'm right in the middle of filming like an intense character moment
and Spencer comes walking in
"So Sam and Niko got hacked!"
Just like *weird gasping noise*
And we're doing all the...
What happened?
*Gasp*
And all the descriptions say something different too.
Niko thinks it either Sam's Corridor Digital e-mail or the...
the third-party app so we are going to be looking into both of those,
uninstall them, changing passwords.
Worst hacking that it's ever been?
This is, this is legitimately bad situation.
Ugh, I'm so pissed right now but I can't be mad 'cause I have to fix this.
Aw, what? Is that it?
How do you know that?
Confirmed, Studio 71 has been hacked
partners data has been leaked.
So check out another channel that is partnered with them to see...
What's another channel?
The Rock!
I'm on there now.
Oh, yeah! Roman Atwood has been hit aswel!
Holy shit!
Dude, this is across the board!
Wow
Wait, Epic Meal Time?
Yeah...
Every...
Everyone with Studio 71 has been hacked.
No one touch any of the channels.
Yeah, because this here because they're claiming it.
Remove access...
Dude, what the fuck?
What the fuck?!
Studio 71 man!
Well...
At least if it's that big, we can probably just count on Youtube to revert everything
rather than having to fix it all ourselves.
Yeah...
Guys...
The Rock's channel is totally fine.
They're doing
They're the only of the MCN to be doing this live stream during *inaudible*
I don't know if that's like opened up some weird gate or whatever but...
I'm trying to revoke but the problem is they claim.
So...
the fucking way that it's set up is we're not even...
we can't even tell 'em not to...
Uhm...
Yeah, we can't revoke it.
Yeah...
So hashtag #Ourmine if you guys are curious.
Dickhead.
Who's the fucking dickhead?
Somebody messed up!
Someone is going to get fired.
What the fuck?!
Something looks wrong!
Look at this!
Do we even have a list of all the titles and stuff?
Of all of our videos?
No, this is where Studio 71 has got to go to Youtube and be like "Help us!"
and the Youtube...
They just reset everything to like a snapshot or something?
They should be able to revert everything.
Yeah, I mean, you're right. There should be some sort of snapshot, like,
on the hour that it will just get rolled back to
I've changed both the passwords, I have removed Studio 71 from our ad works.
Hey.
Hey, what's up? I'm here!
I came as fast as I could!
Guys, you know what we should do?
We should just go outside.
You wanna go outside?
Yeah, let's go get some air.
Let's go outside!
Is there any of that?
Our computers are all secured.
It was the third-party...
It was our MCN that shot us over.
Yeah.
Dude.
So, how likely do you think it was Peter 42?
I knew it!
I've been spending the entire day outside, it's been lovely!
We had a shot where I had to drop a bottle of the roof of the building.
And it was like, there's no way you're gonna hit the mark.
It's like a hundred foot drop. There's wind, it's gonna be completely impossible.
There's no way you're gonna do it.
And I'm like, first I'm just gonna do it with the plastic bottle, fill it with water, just test it out.
Whiffed it hard with the plastic bottle!
I had one more plastic bottle, just to double check it.
Whiffed it again with the plastic bottle.
So it comes to the time, you get the real shot, I have a real breakable bottle half filled with water
All the cameras are lined up, I fucking ace it.
Right in the bullseye!
Great! I got high fives from everybody!
I really like the new branding we've gone with on the channel.
Yeah, I think if we named every single video the same titled it will probably be moved up in the algorithm.
Consistency is key.
See, now we share the same title with all the Roman Atwood vlogs, all the Epic Meal Time
I mean, this is probably really gonna work out for the better for us.
Rocket Jump is ok.
If VGHS gets deleted of Youtube...
It will not exist
Oh yeah, that's right!
Season one!
'Cause there's no hard copy!
If it gets deleted it will exist on Netflix.
Freddy is literally downloading it right now.
There's like a loading bar!
Anytime anybody asks you to sign for a third-party cracker thing...
NOPE!
I feel like throwing up...
Really?
Yeah...
What if they delete all of our videos?
You know, in Good Will Hunting, when he sits down with those military engineer... people?
And he's like "Yes", and they're like "We want you to come work for the CIA and hack code" and he is like...
He goes on that whole spiel about how, whatever...
Those are the type of people that better be hired by Google...
for moments like this.
I think you just revert...
They just revert Youtube.
Youtube Rewind!
Hashtag Youtube Rewind guys!
Ah, fuck...